was there a time in your career where
you started to expect that every leading
man would fall in love with you in the
book there's this theme Elliot Gould you
went into a play one of your first play
your first but I didn't think I wanted
him to fall in love with me I mean
that's how it happened then the Sydney
chaplain you fell in love those are love
stories I mean those Omar
Shar I mean you ended up don't make me
laugh please but Barbara you ended up in
love with a lot of and they ended up
love with you when you go into a movie
with Robert Redford you're like well
we're probably going to end up being in
love no he was a married man with three
children I had no designs on him you
know I totally respected who he was and
his family believe me I don't These Guys
these guys are all seduced by you they
all almost that's their problem right
but it does happen you have to admit if
when I read this book I went I had no
idea like it's Danger ous to be on a set
with barbar strand because you you
you're making me laugh but it's true no
no when you're playing a love story if
you're really good at acting your part
some part of you has to fall in love
with that leading man absolutely you
know yes and then when the picture's
over you're over Marlon Brando the way
you describe in the book it's an ongoing
relationship I take it from reading the
book at least I got the impression many
times he came on to you told you he
wanted to [__] you I mean he was that
blatant about it but I I said to my
editor can I just say
f-- k Why does that make you
uncomfortable because that's the Shy
part of me Marlon looked at you he
whispered in you he says I want to [__]
you and I said to him that sounds
horrible and then because it was so it
was just so no I like romance I like
getting to know someone I don't but I
mean it was intriguing it was
flattering but then he said something
that I have always thought I have always
thought when I went to museums alone as
a teenager and looked at the art I
thought this is something I'd like to
share with someone that means something
to me and he said that incredible thing
that was romantic to me I'd like to go
to a museum with you I
said when are we going it seems to me
that the relationship was consummated
that in fact the two of you did become
lovers but you don't spell it out for us
no no no no no no yeah it never happened
right because when he said to me you
know I want you to come to the desert
with me and we'll stay in the desert
overnight I thought what the hell what
are we going to carry a toothbrush and a
bottle of water I mean I think
practically you're not looking for
camping experiences you had enough of
that yeah but it was great to go with
him for the day so we could talk to each
other
like uh our whole experience our
childhoods our mothers and fathers and
Edward aruro had Marlin on television
and his father was on with him Edward
aruro asked the father what do you think
of your your son's Talent or some
sentence like that it's the H you know
he's he's okay you know it was like it
it went right to my heart right I knew
Marlin and I had a lot to
communicate about did it um blow your
mind that this guy you used to watch in
the movies who had this perfect face and
the perfect lips and the way he
described did it blow your mind that
you'd gotten to a point in Show Business
where you're hanging out with this guy
in the desert I mean it's just got to be
yeah yeah cuz I because I was also
outside myself you know the self was
sitting we we stopped at a lunchette
it's like you see in the movies you know
like the luncheon Nets in the midwest
there's three stools and one other
customer you know and the guy behind the
counter and I'm thinking to myself I am
sitting here in this little
faka you know hamburger joint and I'm
with Marl and Brando yes in other words
I couldn't be I couldn't not think that
that was the truth you
know